bonjour abdellah el fergie merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on l'a dit le confinement au maroc a été
prolongée d'un mois alors que l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
arrivé à son terme on imagine que les
marocains sont un peu surpris de cette
décision c'est aussi votre cas
oui bon ne sont pas surpris parce que
bon on attendait plus de deux mois et
les tpe pme de notre confédération et
les autres tp plus de quatre millions
d'électeurs marocains plus de 95 de
l'économie du maroc attendait avec
impatience de redémarrer leur travail
surtout que pire ils sont très
fragilisée avant et pendant et après ce
sera après le confinement et quelles
vont être les conséquences de ce mois
supplémentaires de confinement pour les
entreprises marocaines écouter s'il n'y
a pas d'accompagnement l'on nous avons
demandé aux chefs de commandos du
gouvernement personne au co présidents
de comités dv qu'il faut qu'ils aient un
accompagnement pour c'était surtout les
tpe que non plus on qui sont au bout du
gouffre et qui n'arrivent pas à joindre
les deux bouts surtout pendant les temps
normal alors que cette crise a trop duré
et qu'il faut qu'ils aient un
accompagnement de des autorités surtout
2.2.2 financiers aient accès aux
commandes publiques donc il faut qu'ils
à l'accompagnement
il faut que l'état marocain et foot les
tpe et non pas que le patronat
malheureusement l'état maroc al discute
simplement avec le patronat et
délaissent les 95 de l'économie du maroc
et quel est l'état aujourd'hui des
entreprises marocaines est ce que
certaines sont actuellement au bord du
gouffre notez le le début de
l'apparition du courant d'un virus on a
relancé une étude le 18 mars jusqu'au 10
avril pour voir l'état de situation de
cet ep permet surtout et les auto
entrepreneurs
l'étude nous avait démontré que 83% des
deux de ces types d'entreprises sont à
l'arrêt total et juste 13% qui étaient
en activité partielle
alors imaginez pendant deux ans les les
la plupart des tpe qui était en arrêt
total attendait avec impatience
l'arrivée de déconfinement pour
reprendre leur travail alors qu'on
conseilleront des comptes qui est des
encore des restrictions vis-à-vis des
grands pôles économiques casablanca
rabat tanger et marrakech
merci adel el fehri d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france pour nous
parler de la situation des entreprises
au maroc
elle rappelle que vous êtes le président
de la confédération marocaine des
tpe/pme merci beaucoup